thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 off go to drinkhydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman steadymd
lets you maintain a meaningful long
lasting relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only ninety nine dollars a month
with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started all right we have
very important breaking news today
and it's it's actually not all bad news
uh the coronavirus
vaccine from pfizer and bioentech has
been approved
for emergency use in the united kingdom
and this is a huge deal for a number of
different reasons some obvious so maybe
less
obvious to people um who are planning to
get the vaccine because you need to
understand
what's going on in the mind of the
anti-vaxxers in order to understand
some some of the relevance here so i'll
explain it all to you
so first and foremost the vaccine
approved in the uk
for emergency use this first vaccine uh
is the same vaccine that was submitted
for approval in the united states made
by pfizer
and bioentec german and american
companies
the fda is meeting next week to decide
on emergency use approval
here in the united states as well in the
uk
their own agency the medicines and
health care products
regulatory agency which licenses drugs
in the united kingdom looked at the
trial data as you know the trial data
indicates that this vaccine is 95
effective at generating immunity to the
coronavirus and said
yes the data is good let's start
vaccinating people now it is still going
to be labeled experimental
until final testing is done this is
similar to here in the u.s
if the fda approves it next week
i believe they are meeting um wednesday
thursday friday next week or maybe
right right around that time in the u.s
it would be given an emergency use
authorization not a full approval
equivalent situation happening in the uk
the uk
now expects 800 000 doses
within days and they expect people to be
receiving
the vaccine really as soon as that
happens potentially monday
in the uk they are talking about this is
happening and it is a really really big
deal it is
the start of and it is going to be a
long tunnel
but we are starting to see the light at
the end of the tunnel now this vaccine
uh different than the moderna vaccine
the pfizer bioentec vaccine
requires storage at minus 70 degrees
celsius so it's believed that all of the
initial vaccination
in the uk is going to be happening at
hospitals that already
uh have or were able to set up the
equipment to store vaccines at that cold
temperature now the reasons that this is
so important some are obvious and some
are not so obvious we need a vaccine and
this is a 100-year global pandemic
with what in the u.s is soon to be a 911
a day in terms of deaths
we need a vaccine and so this is huge
but the reason that this is also
important specifically because the uk
has done this is that there are people
in the u.s
who are not necessarily anti-vaxxers in
general
but they're worried about the safety of
a vaccine
that is simply approved when donald
trump is president the idea being that
any agency including the fda
could maybe be influenced by donald
trump into approving something that
should not yet be approved
now we've heard from anthony fauci that
that's not the case
once it became clear that despite donald
trump's pleading
in july august and september none of the
pharmaceutical companies developing
vaccines
pushed for approval before the election
i was increasingly reassured
that we're not going to see haphazard
rushed approval requests
from pharmaceutical companies but if you
were still worried about that
we now have a different country's health
regulatory agency that has said
this same vaccine is okay to use
so the point is if you just don't trust
the fda under trump even if trump is now
a lame duck and is unlikely to still be
pushing them to do anything they
shouldn't do
you can say i'm going to go by the
british
health regulatory agency's decision soon
we're expecting the same thing from the
eu's health regulatory agency
it's the same vaccine the pfizer
bioentech vaccine
and here in the u.s as soon as next
weekend
spoke to a doctor recently on the west
coast who said
we have been told expect to get
vaccinated
maybe next weekend or just a couple of
days after that
this is a major achievement pfizer says
it can produce
80 million doses this year which would
be for 40 million people
and 1.3 billion doses next year which
would be enough for 650 million people
remembering that you need two doses this
is
needed acutely the numbers in the u.s
are
brutal we've not yet even seen the
impact of the millions and millions of
people who traveled
for thanksgiving to gather indoors and
then travel home
and we still had yesterday 2614 deaths
yesterday we saw the most deaths in a
single day
dating all the way back to april 21st
and within days we are expecting to
absolutely blow through those numbers
within a week we could see the most
deaths in a single day of the entire
pandemic
we are very close to a 11's worth of
deaths
every single day now the ship has sailed
on convincing a huge part of this
country about how serious this is
and the tragedy is that lots of those
same people who refuse to behave
responsibly
also aren't interested in a vaccine and
we're going to have to figure out how we
deal with that i don't know the answer
as i spoke about
with congressman ro khanna yesterday
these vaccines initially will not be
given to children
so if you look at our population bearing
in mind we need about 70
immunity for hurt immunity that means
close to every adult has to be
vaccinated
for herd immunity given that children
will not be eligible for vaccines
initially
this is an uphill battle and the tragic
irony of the people demanding everything
go back to normal right away
those are the same people refusing to do
the things that would actually help us
to get back to normal so great news from
the uk
we're keeping an eye on whether we will
get a press conference from the fda
next week announcing their decision
about this same pfizer
bioentec vaccine and uh we will we will
make every effort to cover that press
conference live
if indeed it happens joe biden has made
a major selection to his cabinet pick
for his incoming cabinet that i
wholeheartedly
absolutely think is a disastrous choice
and uh that is the choice of near a
tendon
to lead omb omb is the office of
management and budget that's a cabinet
level position
i believe this is by far joe biden's
worst selection
i like many of joe biden's picks
alejandro
mayorkas for the department of homeland
security secretary
super interesting a good pick well
qualified
janet yellen for treasury we've already
talked about her i think that's a good
pick
there's a long list of good selections
by joe biden and all qualified
but nera tandon is a disastrous
selection and is a sign of cow towing to
the worst
of the worst of the establishment
democratic party cronyism
that is off-putting and distasteful and
disgusting
niro tandon is primarily known
as a hillary clinton loyalist to put it
put to put it plainly
uh one of these democratic elites that
helped
sink bernie back in 2016. she's proposed
cutting social security in the past
back in 2010 near a tandon was involved
in a center for american progress which
is the
the organization she ran a cap proposal
to cut
social security but not only do i think
this is a bad pick
because it is exactly the type of
democratic party cronyism that the party
should be getting away from
i also think this is a bad pick because
it's controversial on both sides with
many republicans thinking that niro
tandon is just bonkers
and progressives thinking she's a true
centrist establishment
shill that is the epitome of the problem
of the democratic party so you've got
the bernie left furious because they see
this
as just a smack in the face her
organization regularly going after
bernie as i already mentioned
but you've also got right wingers who
think nero tandon
is nuts republican senator lindsey
graham calling nera tandon
a quote nut job and i don't really care
what crazy republicans think about joe
biden's picks
except that they will
have the ability to create real
obstacles for confirmation
and it will be a battle for joe biden to
get
someone confirmed that much of the left
doesn't like either
a lindsey graham saying quote if you
want to make sure this nut job tandon
doesn't become the director of the
budget in charge of omb
then make sure we win georgia so
republicans using this
to try to win those races in georgia
they may create obstacles and
it'll be a confirmation battle the
progressive wing of the democratic party
is disgusted and republicans have
already signaled
that they could block confirmation of
nera tandon
the left and right both have problems
this
is definitely not in keeping by the way
with joe biden's unite the country theme
unless he means unite the country
against near a tandem
i see no gain from this politically i
see no
benefit from this for a biden
administration just in terms of the
day-to-day
now much of the case being made for nira
tandon
is an identity case she grew up in
section 8 housing and now she's going to
run the national budget
okay but she could run it in a good way
or a bad way the fact that she grew up
in section 8 housing doesn't tell us
whether she's a good or bad pick
she's the first indian american in this
position
okay but is she the right person for it
and as i've said before
identity can be enlightening and
informative
if the person is otherwise qualified
kamala harris
is a very well qualified person to be
vice president
she could be president on day one if it
were necessary and
it's very interesting and inspiring that
she will be the first female president
or vice president ever in history
that's really interesting that's
inspiring that's relevant
but if she were unqualified being a
woman
wouldn't be a reason to put her in that
position and in seeing many of the
defenses of near attendance so far
i'm seeing experience and connections
mentioned
which means she's an insider okay and
i'm seeing identity stories which by
themselves don't do too much for me
now in the meantime nira tandon has been
on a tweet delete rampage deleting about
1800 tweets
many of them critical of bernie sanders
and of elizabeth warren
so to be clear i can be against this
selection and be in favor of others
yesterday on a live stream i mentioned i
don't at all like this selection of nira
tandon
and i started getting emails and
messages from people saying david why
are you attacking joe biden this is not
the time to attack biden
listen biden won and he's going to be
president if saying
i think nera tandon is a bad pick
while lots of other picks are good and
if that counts as attacking joe biden
we're going to have a long four years
ahead of us my friends but i think most
of the audience understands
um i can dislike this selection and like
others and still believe that voting for
joe biden over donald trump was the
right choice
as i did and as i continue to believe
let me know your thoughts what am i
missing
am i misguided in my criticism of nira
tandon let me know i'm on twitter at d
pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history
of time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about 8 bucks a month and you
get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right remember that this program is
mostly funded we depend on
people like you who presumably like the
show i guess you could support it even
if you hate it
who go to joinpakman.com and they get a
membership
it's quick it's easy it's very
inexpensive and you'll get instant
access
to the award-winning bonus show they are
all awards given out by producer pat
i admit that i don't know how valuable
those are but they are awards
nonetheless
grab a membership at joinpakman.com
we do have hatred mail really ramping up
lately and we've been doing like triple
duty on hatred mail we've been posting
some hatred mail to my instagram we've
been posting hatred mail to twitter
and we still have hatred mail on the
show just a quick reminder about what
that is
the coveted vaccine we're praising our
savior donald trump
for delivering is the very same one
we'll refuse to take
because bill gates put microchips in it
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
all right so much of this hatred mail
there's two themes since the election
one is the hatred mail has become
significantly more anti-semitic
maybe not a surprise and number two the
hatred mail has become much more focused
on how trump actually won which probably
also is not a surprise given the
narrative from the right over the last
month
let's take a listen to this week's
pacman are you
mad that your jew brothers the chabad
will help trump win the election
if he even needs the help pacman you
most be a jew those are the stupid demon
rats that hate trump what a liar you are
skinny jew david pakman has pretty much
lost his plot now
that the whole trump voter fraud thing
is proven
just a heads up what will you do when
trump gets four years again
biden president never going to happen
the voter fraud thing is proven trump's
completely
biased attorney general william barr
has even said there is no evidence of
voter fraud at this time we'll cover
that in a moment
if anyone would be out there saying
there's fraud
if there was even an iota of evidence of
it
it
would be william barr and then again you
know the what is it about the like what
if if you're a trumpist and you're mad
that trump lost
why do you email me and say anti-semitic
things i i continue to fail to see
the causality of why when the right is
mad about anything
they email me anti-semitic things but
what i can tell you
that i'm very confident in is that the
best way
to fight patriotism in your community
is to get a membership on my website
with the coupon code hatred 40.
it's a beautiful thing you sign up at
joinpakman.com
you enter the coupon code hatred 40
h-a-t-r-i-o-t 4-0
you say 40 percent and the hatreds cry
because their messages are not hurting
the show that's the way to do it
okay you might remember this guy named
william barr
he is the attorney general after all
he's donald trump's
hatchet man attorney general and he
up until yesterday had all but
completely disappeared from the public
eye
since he attended that white house super
spreader event
for donald trump's supreme court pick
amy coney barrett
that was that event which set in motion
this chain of coronavirus cases
barr went missing for a while after that
point
bar resurfaced yesterday to say without
any hesitation
at this point there is no evidence of
widespread
election fraud that would have affected
the election results in any way
now you still have people saying well
what about this one vote
a dead person really did vote the point
is
there is no evidence at this point of
fraud of any materially significant
nature to the election you also
immediately had counter articles coming
out saying no
barr didn't clear everybody of fraud
what barr said is
to date there is no evidence
of materially significant election fraud
he said this in an interview yesterday
with the associated press
his exact statement was quote to date
to date we have not seen fraud on a
scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election
there's been one assertion that would be
systemic fraud
and that would be the claim that
machines were programmed to skew the
election results
and the dhs and doj have looked into
that and so far
we haven't seen anything to substantiate
that
as this was breaking donald trump
tweeting quote
hope everybody's watching oan right now
other media afraid to show
people are coming forward like never
before
large truck carrying hundreds of
thousands
of fraudulent fake ballots to a voting
center
terrible save america so at this point
donald trump's claims are sort of a
running parallel commentary
that's completely divorced from all the
facts on the ground
and then immediately after william barr
said this there was speculation that
donald trump was going to fire him
because within moments of that
interview being published a william barr
was seen arriving
at the white house and the speculation
was oh boy trump called him in and he's
gonna fire him right now
that's not at all what was going on that
was a pre-planned meeting
with uh the chief of staff mark meadows
cnn's caitlyn collins reporting that
quote
attorney general barr is in the west
wing
for a meeting with mark meadows an
official says
the meeting was planned before his
interview with the associated press
now it certainly wouldn't be beyond
trump
to fire william barr for saying this
that would actually be
totally unsurprising but the speculation
that the timing of barr going to the
white house after saying yesterday
no evidence of election fraud um
that was mere speculation and he was
actually there to meet with the chief of
staff mark meadows
now there are all sorts of other things
going on involving the justice
department
some not very good for trump which could
have been the reasons
for william barr or at least the subject
matter of william barr's meeting with
chief of staff mark meadows let's talk
about one of those
next as if donald trump
needed any more scandals
this could be the scandal of all
scandals we have learned
that the justice department is
investigating
a possible cash for trump
pardons scheme understand what this
means the idea
is there are people out there who want
to be pardoned by donald trump before
trump leaves office in about seven weeks
the idea that is being investigated is
that you could pay someone to go and
talk to trump
about pardoning you and it is absolutely
and utterly insane
we knew trump would issue corrupt and
cronyistic pardons he did so with
michael flynn last week
he did so with roger stone some months
ago
but a cash for pardons scandal is
another level altogether and we learned
about the existence of this
investigation
because of the release of some very
redacted court documents that call this
a bribery for
pardon scheme a ton of the 18-page
document that was released
a ton of it is blacked out it's redacted
entire swaths
large sections even almost whole pages
blacked out
nobody who is involved has yet been
named
in the redacted documents presumably
they are named in the unredacted
documents
but what the document does say is that
federal prosecutors in washington say
they've obtained evidence of a bribery
scheme
in which someone would offer a big
political contribution
in exchange for a presidential pardon or
reprieve
of sentence the order said prosecutors
were also investigating a secret
lobbying scheme
in which two unidentified individuals
would lobby senior white house officials
about pardons without uh disclosing that
without being registered properly as
part of the lobbying disclosure act
the justice department wanted to keep
this private because it detailed
individuals and conduct that hasn't yet
led to charges
and it is an absolutely insane series of
allegations now i want to be really
clear
just because the pardons would
ultimately be issued by donald trump
doesn't mean that this was people giving
trump money for pardons it's really
important that we understand that it
wouldn't be surprising to me given
trump's massive debts
if people were offering trump money for
pardons that's not
what we as of now believe is going on
the idea for now seems to be
that if you want a pardon you pay
someone
that someone goes and talks to senior
white house officials
the idea being the white house officials
then go to trump and maybe never
disclose that there is this whole
bribery situation going on and say
hey sir mr president you should really
look at pardoning this person or that
person so it's still very early
um but my mind goes to how
bad must this be if donald trump's
own attorney general william barr's doj
is investigating and what i mean by that
is william barr is one of the most
corrupt attorneys general
we've ever seen in terms of political
cronyism and partisanship
even william barr had to say there's no
evidence of widespread voter fraud which
we covered earlier today
i can't imagine that william barr would
be eager to bring charges for criminal
pardon bribery
but for william barr to even have his
justice department investigating this
means that there
has been a relatively high threshold met
already
this entire issue of pardons of course
is a bigger issue
you know the imagine a president
ordering people to assassinate a
political enemy
and then pardoning them as an example um
the the entire pardon process
and infrastructure is riddled with
uh corruption cronyism and lends itself
to all sort all sorts of malfeasance
but we are now getting to investigations
that are the types of things you see
more often
in developing and poorer countries not
typically the united states
but it's at least possibly happening
here scandal
after scandal after scandal and
you know we've got seven weeks left what
will we
learn about in these last seven weeks
what will trump
do in these last seven weeks and then
once he's out of office
what are we going to learn i i don't
believe that we will ever see
trump indicted prosecuted or jailed as
many of my viewers would like to see and
as some of my
viewers believe will happen but i do
believe that there is going to be
another shoe that drops
after donald trump is out of office uh
about all sorts of allegations
of things he and the people around him
did and a lot of this explains
why donald trump is now considering
pardoning preemptively
his own children son-in-law and rudy
giuliani
we will talk about that after the break
in the meantime
make sure you're following me on
instagram
david.pacman also follow the show on
instagram for more clips and extra
content
david pakman show on instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit drink powder that you
mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you
25 off your first order it's made with
four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
so the grift and the corruption are both
coming full circle rudy giuliani has
reportedly discussed
a blanket preemptive pardon from
president donald trump in these last
seven weeks before trump leaves office
trump also reportedly considering
preemptive
blanket pardons for three of his
children as well as his son-in-law jared
kushner the new york times can report
based on multiple sources
told about the conversation that rudy
giuliani as recently as last week
was talking to donald trump about a
pardon it's not
clear as of yet whether rudy giuliani
originally brought it up to trump or
whether trump brought it up to giuliani
but there have now reportedly been
multiple conversations the most recent
one was last week
donald trump has reportedly not yet
decided what he will do
about pardoning rudy giuliani and the
same questions remain
about trump pardoning jared kushner as
well as his children
ivanka don jr and eric
now trump reportedly not considering a
pardon for tiffany trump
i guess he doesn't expect that she might
uh be charged with anything
but the the immediate question is pardon
from what rudy hasn't even been charged
with anything
neither have his children and that is
exactly the question that's raising the
most attention
it's not actually clear what rudy
giuliani might be charged with in the
future
but the fact that it's being discussed
multiple times at the highest levels
is very interesting we know that rudy
was being investigated last summer by
federal investigators for maybe
violating lobbying law through the work
he did
with ukraine but beyond that it's not
exactly clear now what we do know
is that as a general concept the idea
here is that
with regard to his children and
son-in-law at least and it may be
similar with rudy giuliani
donald trump believes that there will be
partisan
investigations and possibly prosecutions
of his children
after he leaves office and so it's not
because from from trump's perspective
it's not that he thinks his kids
committed crimes
it's that he thinks they didn't but they
might be charged with crimes anyway by a
partisan joe biden administration
what you know there's this funny thing
um
trump always projects his
immorality and his do whatever for a
buck
or whatever for revenge sort of attitude
on other people
trump is worried biden would go after
trump's kids
even though they didn't do anything as
far as trump is concerned
because that's exactly what trump would
do if he were joe biden but joe biden
has clearly shown no interest and has
even said
he has no plan to direct his justice
department to do anything of the sort
but a lot of trump's behavior is
motivated by what trump
imagines he would do if in someone
else's position
now rudy giuliani's spokeswoman was
asked
about the seeking a pardon and she said
giuliani can't comment on any
discussions he's had with his client
trump being his client so what we're
talking about here
are blanket broad open-ended
pre-emptive pardons this is very rare
but it has happened in the past
george washington yeah we have to go
back we don't have to go back that far
but one
notable example goes back to george
washington who pardoned
those who were plotting the whiskey
rebellion so that they wouldn't be
prosecuted for treason
gerald ford pardoned richard nixon for
all his actions as president now
it is important to remember a few
important things about presidential
pardons number one
they work for federal crimes not state
crimes so if
the southern district of new york as an
example were to bring charges against
rudy or ivanka or whoever we're still
not sure for what but if they did
the pardon from trump wouldn't protect
them there number two
whether preemptive blanket pardons work
is a legal question and what i mean by
that is a president
can do it and in the past these
preemptive pardons
have dissuaded anybody from prosecuting
the pardoned individuals like for
example
when gerald ford pardoned richard nixon
the pardon
was challenged legally it was found to
be constitutional
but it was never brought to the supreme
court it is conceivable that a supreme
court could
say a blanket preemptive pardon is not
okay
whether it ever gets to the supreme
court is a question
and you know with with the supreme court
we have right now
i'm not sure this supreme court is going
to rule against
blanket pre-emptive pardons from donald
trump
so that's one part of this now as far as
donald trump is concerned
he just pardoned his convicted former
national security adviser michael flynn
last week
he previously commuted the sentence of
roger stone
he also pardoned less well-known people
now just a funny side note
things are so crazy right now that when
i read the original headline about this
story
i thought maybe rudy and trump talked
about trump pardoning
trump the first headline i saw said
something like
giuliani discussed a preemptive pardon
with trump
that could mean giuliani talked to trump
about trump pardoning rudy
but it could also mean that as his
lawyer giuliani talked to trump about
trump pardoning
himself and a self-pardon is a
completely different story
unclear whether that is something donald
trump could do so the long and short of
it is
rudy wants immunity for everything no
matter what in perpetuity and a sort of
free pass
and that would be for things what let me
see how i can say this the right way
the the pardon can't be for things that
you do after the pardon so in other
words
if rudy is pardoned and the next day
commits a federal crime
the legal consensus is that would not be
covered by a presidential pardon
we're going to follow it many pardons
coming from donald trump in the next
seven weeks for sure
the small business administration
released a bunch of data
about the businesses that received ppp
money
and eidl loans through
the coronavirus stimulus that was done
some months ago
and immediately a very troubling pattern
was revealed
in which donald trump's own businesses
and his son-in-law jared kushner's own
businesses benefited hugely
from these funds listen to some of what
we've learned
25 ppp loans worth more than
3.6 million dollars were given to
businesses with addresses
at trump and kushner real estate
properties
paying rent to trump and kushner so
that's
indirect trump and kushner benefited
from rent money that was obtained by
their tenants
from ppp that's number one number two
15 of those properties self-reported
that they only kept one job zero
jobs or simply didn't report jobs
retained
thanks to that money loans to trump and
kushner properties
include a two million dollar loan to the
triumph restaurant corporation located
inside trump hotel and tower in new york
city
they reported that the money did not go
to keeping any jobs
and then they closed down i'll take the
money
then i'll close and i'll keep the money
a company called lb city incorporated
which is located at kushner's
bungalow hotel in jersey received the
loan for half a million bucks
and used that to keep some jobs two
tenants at 725 fifth avenue which is
trump tower received more than a hundred
thousand dollars and kept only
three jobs three jobs total four tenants
at the kushner owned
in the infamous six six six five six six
six fifth avenue in manhattan
received more than two hundred thousand
dollars and kept only six jobs and this
entire thing has ended up being
a major cash grab for trump and kushner
directly and indirectly over 100 loans
we also learned
were made to companies where no business
name was listed in the field where
you're supposed to put in your business
name to get the money
they either put in uh nothing or like
it listed a phone number or a date like
that could be a clerical error but it
also might not be
i go and ask for a loan and they say oh
uh what what's the business name
oh the business name is june 17th oh
sure here have some money so first of
all none of this should come as a shock
obviously trump and his family were
going to take advantage of this money
in any way that they could but meanwhile
remember that we're supposed to believe
we can't afford health care
we can't afford uh to make sure nobody
goes hungry
we can't afford to forgive student loan
debt we can't even afford a 15
an hour minimum wage we can't do
mortgage and rent relief
during coronavirus but look at all of
this money that is just flying around
much of which should not be
remember that right after the stimulus
was approved
donald trump removed the person in
charge of oversight of stimulus funds
so it was obvious that they were going
to do this from day one
trump and kushner grifted the hell out
of the coronavirus
stimulus money but we're supposed to
believe joe biden is the socialist and
that's where you know when you come
around
the truth really doesn't matter when you
have
nearly half the country so radicalized
by ideas like trust fox news and joe
biden
is a socialist and trump will fix all of
your problems
that it doesn't matter what the facts on
the ground
are and understand the contrast here for
example
um i mean listen i've talked i've told
the story before i'll
tell it again i my uh lawyer and
accountant contacted me when the
stimulus stuff
was was announced and said you you can
get money
you can get money and you won't have to
pay it back like you could just take
money
and at the time i mean maybe i did the
wrong maybe i'm the naive one
but at the time i said listen uh we've
lost some ad revenue but i've gone to
the audience and i've said listen we
we need your support i get that a lot of
people are in tough financial situations
but get a membership pay five bucks a
month if you can afford it
and enough people did where i said to
our lawyer and accountant
let's not do it it just doesn't feel
right like i don't feel like we're
really struggling in the way that some
of these small businesses that are
physical businesses rather than virtual
businesses
they're struggling really badly it feels
as though any dollar i take
might be a dollar i'm taking away from
somebody else uh
and meanwhile uh you have companies
like the ones that trump and kushner run
and rent to
taking money money money closing in some
cases
and not having to pay the money back and
listen maybe i should have taken it
right i mean i've spoken on live streams
about how
in the last month we've had hundreds and
hundreds of people have to cancel
memberships because they've lost jobs
or didn't get jobs back or had hours cut
because of what's going on
maybe i should have taken the money but
then that would make me as bad as them
wouldn't it
uh so it's a really um it it there's a
lot of
ambiguity but it certainly didn't feel
like this money was intended for me it
sure as hell
should not have been intended for
billionaires who can float their
businesses on their own but are choosing
not to
disgusting stuff and i can only imagine
i can only imagine how much more we're
going to learn about this
in the next few weeks as we continue to
comb through the data
let's take a quick break we'll be back
after this much more to discuss
on this very important day the uk
approving a coronavirus vaccine for
emergency use
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with an
in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so gabriel sterling is the voting
implementation manager with the
georgia secretary of state's office and
he has had enough of trump
and went off yesterday during a public
statement
telling donald trump that he's gone too
far
that election workers are being
threatened and targeted in georgia
thanks to the things donald trump has
been saying and that donald trump must
stop inspiring his followers to be
violent
right away check out these videos and
again this is
lifelong republican gabriel sterling
who works for the republican georgia
secretary of state saying trump has gone
too far
and he is complicit in the harassment
and targeting of poll workers
and other election workers in the state
of georgia
it has all gone too
far
all of it
today asked for chris krebs ace patriot
who ran sissa
to be shot a 20-something tech
in gwinnett county today has death
threats and a noose
put out saying he should be hung for
treason because he was transferring
a report on batches from an ems
to a county computer so he could read it
it has to stop
mr president you have not condemned
these actions or this language
senators you have not condemned this
language or these actions
never but i mean he says trump hasn't
condemned it trump has encouraged it
we're like a few layers removed uh
certainly there hasn't been condemnation
because donald trump has been
encouraging this behavior and again just
a reminder
this is a lifelong conservative
republican
gabriel sterling voting implementation
manager with the secretary of state in
the state of georgia georgia of course
one of the states that donald trump
lost to joe biden but insists
that he actually won let's see a little
bit more video here
as the secretary said yesterday people
aren't giving you the best advice what's
actually going on the ground
it's time to look forward if you want to
run free election
in four years fine do it but everything
we're
seeing right now there's not a path
be the bigger man here and stop step in
tell your supporters don't be violent
don't intimidate all that's wrong it's
un-american
the republican party owns the crazy
right now but when you have
one guy like this who says enough is
enough
he instantly gets attacked by trumpists
here is gabriel sterling
essentially explaining stochastic
terrorism i don't
he doesn't he's not using this term and
i don't think he even recognizes that
he's doing it but
he's he's effectively doing it when
gabriel sterling says
some people because trump has so many
people that listen to him
some people will hear the stuff he says
and someone could do something violent
on donald trump say so check it out
and you know there are people who can be
have some righteous intonation be angry
but there's also people out there at
this point in the social media world we
see what happens
there are some nut balls out there who
are going to take this thing the
president told me to do this
essentially you have to be responsible
you have to be responsible in your
rhetoric you have to be responsible in
your statements
you have to be responsible in your deeds
that shouldn't be too much to ask for
people who ask
for us to give them responsibility this
is really the crux
of stochastic terrorism which is the
idea that
given a big enough audience it starts to
become
likely and probable that
if a media figure plants a certain idea
in the minds of their audience if
there's
you know if you attack someone every day
on your show
and your audience is 100 people
it's not super likely that your attacks
will motivate anybody to actually go
and try to kill that person as an
example but if your audience is a
million
or 10 million or you know 80 million as
trump's audience is on twitter
including certainly some bots but okay
80 million roughly
uh even if it's only a 1 in 80 million
chance that somebody will hear what you
say and go and attack someone
once you have 80 million people that are
listening to what you say that starts to
become probable
and likely and that's essentially what
gabriel sterling is referring to here
and of course he's absolutely correct
he's saying the right thing
now at the same time gabriel sterling
has been part of the machine in georgia
that has been suppressing the vote in
ways
republicans believe are advantageous
trying to suppress the non-white vote
trying to suppress the non-rich vote for
a long time
and you've got a lot of people now
holding up gabriel sterling as some kind
of hero because
look he republican takes on trump right
now
as far as we know he's taking on trump
because his friends are poll workers
and it's all about protecting his
friends and it's not really about
running fair elections
i don't know one way or or the other but
the point is
he's saying the right thing in this
instance he may be saying it for the
right reasons he may not
but georgia is one of the worst places
in the country as far as voter
suppression is concerned
and sterling's been part of it for a
long time he's been part of it as
a a worker as an employee of the
secretary of state's office
he was previously a right-wing
councilman in georgia so
as much as he's not trying to stop
a problem he's identified he's been
a part of the problem for a very very
long time broken clocks
can still be right every once in a while
i think this is one of those examples
trump doesn't care
and he immediately this guy becomes
enemy number one for the trumpists who
believe
because trump keeps saying it and some
fox news hosts keep saying it and so do
others
for the people that believe trump really
did win joe biden really did steal this
thing this isn't going to make a
difference but needless to say it's very
interesting to watch
one of the most sinister characters
in the greek tragedy that has been the
trump
presidency is without a doubt donald
trump's press secretary
kelly mcinanny who also plays a dual
role
on television where sometimes she's not
white house press secretary
but instead she's merely a campaign
advisor for donald trump's presidential
campaign
yesterday i played clips for you of
kaylee
on fox news monday night saying things
about voter fraud
as a campaign advisor and then tuesday
morning i mean we're talking 12 hours 11
hours later maybe even
on a different fox fox show fox and
friends saying
when asked about those claims oh you
know you've got to talk to the campaign
about that because today
i'm here as white house press secretary
how convenient how convenient well
it's this completely kafka-esque
situation that they've created
it's mimetic quite frankly and here is
kaylee
once again last night on sean hannity's
program
holding up now i guess these are ballots
uh previously she's held up reams of
paper
sometimes she'll hold up a book or a
three-ring binder
and this time it's a ballad or a paper
with a lot of sharpie circles on it and
there's there's something particularly
ironic about this one take a look
like this where they actually list out
all of the circles are different ballot
numbers
they've written the specific ballot
number down
that was dated january 1st 1900 for
someone who didn't
so the absolute hilarity is that now
without any sensible legal argument left
to make
with no credible path to overturning the
results in
even a single state never mind the
multiple states they would need to
overturn for for donald trump to win
on the basis of non-existent voter fraud
now she is relegated to talking about
what are essentially confusing layouts
on pieces of paper
and those who have been following
politics for some time may remember
the irony of this because back in the
year 2000
the florida results were the question
with hanging chads and these butterfly
ballots where
the candidate's name was on one side and
there would be an arrow pointing to the
other side and it was unclear okay
that was when republicans didn't want to
do a recount
that was when republicans didn't want to
really look closely and ascertain
what was the intention of this voter
in filling out this ballot they said no
no no
stop the recount secretary of state
catherine florida secretary of state
katherine harris
getting involved the supreme court
getting involved now
after all of their other arguments have
failed and been dismissed by courts as
having no merit
kaylee mcinanni is relegated to saying
the layout is confusing there's stuff
all over the page
look i've circled it with a sharpie
they're pathetic
kaylie continues with her various pieces
of paper check it out
exactly there's no praise i mean this is
one county here
one county where you have literally
hundreds of pages in one county
um in wayne county detroit all across
the country
this is uh i tweeted about this this is
the gish gallop
in paper form that's what this has been
from kaylee mcinanni and
and others who just hold up papers gish
this is actually
this may be instructive to some gish
gallup is a debate term
okay and what it means is
when a debater tries to overwhelm their
opponent
just by making lots of arguments even if
the arguments are bogus right you make
many arguments it's quantity over
quality you make a lot of arguments in a
debate
without regard for the accuracy or the
strength of the arguments
that's called a gish gallop this is gish
gallop by paper
using an excessive number of pieces of
paper to make an
argument based on the idea that you have
so many pieces of paper
with no regard to the accuracy or
strength or validity
or or relevance of any of those pieces
of paper and that's exactly what we've
seen we've seen some of these pieces of
paper
uh say uh that the the poll workers
didn't like how they were treated that
somebody was rude to them
we've seen these pieces of paper refer
to towns that aren't even in the states
where they claim to be indicating there
was voter fraud so for example
there was i'm trying to remember now
there was a filing made
in either pennsylvania or georgia which
said
look at the fraud in michigan in these
five towns
and none of those five towns were in
michigan the five towns were in
minnesota
so it's gish gallop by paper and then
here's just one more where kaylee again
pulls out this term she created
electoral epidemic which is it should be
seen as a joke anyway take a look
stay pandemic and created an electoral
epidemic but we are fighting
new lawsuit today and wisconsin just
filed 366 pages
detailing how wisconsin law was violated
so these people are
well listen i mean if the lawsuit is 366
pages
it must be substantive right and every
time i hear that phrase electoral
epidemic
i think yes it was an epidemic of people
voting in record numbers more people
than ever before
decided to go and vote that's the
epidemic by the way can you believe it's
already been a month since the election
it it's stunning how time is flying and
the good news of that
is trump will be gone from the white
house before you know it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is just a nice
friendly voicemail these are relatively
rare
this is high praise for the show and our
our staff take a look
hey dave john just wanted to thank you
um
i think um everyone would agree
that you've assembled a wonderful team
around you well not not everyone would
agree
not everyone would agree but i'm glad
that at least some people do you should
see my voice my inbox though not
everybody agrees
you have a sense of a greater good and a
logical discourse that allows
others to understand your point of view
even if they don't agree
bravo i love the praise unfortunately
john is giving a lot of the people
in our in our audience too much credit
and i'm i'm talking about the haters
who don't understand what i'm talking
about and they will write to me
defiantly and strongly telling me i was
wrong
about something i didn't even say that
may be actually one of the more you know
people say
the what about the insults through the
insults the insults you get used to
what's
very frustrating is getting emails from
people
furious with me about something i didn't
say
angry with me about an argument i didn't
make um
because it just yeah it's like punching
a paper bag or whatever to
try to pun trying to punch your way out
of a wet paper bag or maybe there's some
other
analogy or metaphor that makes more
sense listen i have something very nice
to announce today
um we've had so much just
deep election related stuff going on
that tomorrow thursday night december
3rd
at 8 p.m eastern i will be co-hosting a
chess
tournament with the international
master levy rosman okay
levy and i are co-hosting this
tournament it starts at 8 p.m eastern
and you can join the david pakman
chess club at chess.com to participate
uh at davidpakman.com
chessdavidpakman.com
chess chessdavidpakman.com chess that'll
redirect you
and you can join my chess.com chess club
this is all free i'm not
selling you anything other than a good
time um tomorrow
starting at 7 eastern you will be able
to register for the tournament which
will start at eight
i will be playing in the tournament and
streaming levy rosman
will be playing in the tournament and
streaming for the first hour
it'll be a 90 minute tournament the last
half hour levy and i will be doing
commentary on the games
of some of the folks who will be leading
uh who are
who are in the lead at that point in
time no chess experience necessary
play a little today get familiar with
the game davidpakman.com
chess i think it will be a great time
it'll be a great break from politics
uh grand master benjamin feingold who's
a supporter of the david pakman show
has agreed to play in the tournament and
there may be some other chess
stars who will be playing so this is if
you if you just want politics this isn't
for you
but if you want to participate in the
community and you like the idea of doing
something a little bit different
i hope you will join us davidpakman.com
chess join the chess club and then
tomorrow night you'll be able to
register
for the tournament all right on the
bonus show today
we now with the approval of the a pfizer
coronavirus vaccine in the uk
and that same approval expected here in
the next seven to ten days
we are starting to see priority lists
about
who should get the vaccine first in what
order
do health care workers go before nursing
home residents
or not these are the types of questions
that are now being discussed
and which we will discuss on today's
bonus show also brazilian
amazon deforestation has surged
and lastly activists have dropped body
bags
outside the homes of a number of
prominent republicans
related to the pandemic related to a
desired
second coronavirus stimulus all of those
stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 off go to drink hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman steadymd
lets you maintain a meaningful long
lasting relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only ninety nine dollars a month
with no
other fees or co-pays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started